direkt gute Nachrichten es gibt ein
neues Hottes Wahlkampfthema und zwar das
ist noch besser endlich mal eins das
fast ohne Fakten auskommt die Angst vor
dem Wolf
er lebt wieder mitten unter uns also
eigentlich schon seit mehr als 20 Jahren
aber ist uns jetzt wieder aufgefallen
vor allem aber wird in Bayern bald
gewählt und da hat sich ein gewisser
Markus Söder gedacht komm so ein böser
Wolf der lässt sich doch prima melden
deswegen kriegt der Freistaat eine neue
wolfsverordnung mit eingebauter
abknallerleichterung das wird den
Viechern eine Lehre sein und tatsächlich
stellen wir fest hat sich in Sachen Wolf
die Stimmung insgesamt so ein bisschen
aufgeheizt Leute die übergriffig werden
müssen weg da ist nicht umsonst ich gehe
dann auch nicht mehr raus wenn es dunkel
ist die müssen entnommen werden sie
haben Berichte Verfolgungsjagd
aufgenommen ich wollte meine Herde
beschützen und
ja schießen darf man sie nicht was soll
man sonst machen ne also überfahren
ja schönes neues Ende für Rotkäppchen
und dann hat der Jäger den Wolf aus dem
Reifenprofil gekratzt
meine klar mehr Wölfe mehr Konflikte mit
nutztierhaltern und deren sorgen muss
man ernst nehmen Markus Söder will vor
allem ihre Stimmen und deswegen hat er
jetzt zum großen Pressetermin auf eine
almeladen
umrahmt von seltsamem Gestalten im
jäger-outfit ja in Bayern reicht ab
sofort ein Riss also ein totes Schaf und
der Wolf ist dran und zwar irgendein
Wolf Schluss mit Beweiskette durchladen
Feierabend
fakt ist aber danach fünf sechs Wochen
wissen wir der eine Wolf ist es und den
einen Wolf den darf man dann vielleicht
entnehmen
jetzt kommt ein bisschen so wie
Aktenzeichen XY wir fahren nach dem
einen Wolf ja und dann nimmt er sich ein
Anwalt hörblos auf so ist immer dasselbe
ne
übrigens gehen Juristen davon aus dass
Söders Verordnung vor Gericht kassiert
wird aber auch das gehört natürlich zum
wahlkampfplan ein paar Tage später hat
der große Beschützer der Schafe übrigens
ein Video seines Mittagessens beim
Türken gepostet inklusive sehr viele
Lammkoteletts ja wirklich wirklich und
nur mal so für Fakten Freunde Nutztiere
machen nur ein bis zwei Prozent des
Speiseplans der in Deutschland lebende
Wölfe aus warte mal da fehlt ein
Aktenzeichen XY für Wölfe immer das ist
doch eine Top Idee
ist das der Wolf der ihre Cousine hat
oder doch der hier hat den hier
irgendjemand von ihnen Mord nach etwas
Verdächtiges bemerkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
leute bitte jetzt nicht alle
durcheinander
ja
das war übrigens ein Ausschnitt aus Soko
Wolfsburg was wir gerade gesehen
auch das soll man nicht verniedlichen
keine Frage das mit den gerissenen
Nutztieren ist in einigen deutschen
Regionen ein echtes Problem und wenn
bestimmte Wölfe was vorkommt lernen wie
man Elektrozäune überwindet muss man sie
wohl entnehmen wie das im Amtsdeutsch so
schön heißt ja entnehmen erst recht wenn
sich verhaltensauffälliges singlewölfe
Siedlung nähern zur Wahrheit gehört aber
auch in 20 Jahren mit Wölfen ist hier
kein einziger Mensch auch nur verletzt
worden zum Vergleich 2022 sind 9
deutsche bei Begegnungen mit Kühen
gestorben
wirklich müssen wir deswegen jetzt die
Milka Kuh entnehmen
und gibt's eigentlich noch ein schöneres
Wort als entnehmen
wir wollen für eine wolfsfreie Zone
sorgen bin ganz Brandenburg am besten
dort wo Weidetiere und Menschen leben
sollte der Wolf sich zurückziehen und
wenn er das nicht alleine lernt dann
müssen wir ihn dabei unterstützen
so
ja unterstützen ist doch nett im Grunde
muss der Wolf einfach nur seine
Ernährung umstellen und ins Gras beißen
so ist der Plan
wolfsfreie Zonen fordern Bauernverbände
was aber gegen geltendes EU-Recht
verstoßen würde war gerade erst großes
Thema beim wolfsgipfel in Berlin so habe
ich mir den vorgestellt
da waren gar keine Wölfe eingeladen
schade schade der Gipfel sollte vor
allem Druck machen auf die Politik um
endlich das Schutzniveau für Wölfe in
Deutschland zu senken hier unser
prominentester Bauer Bayerns Bauer
Ranger Hubert Aiwanger so wird jede
Tierart bewirtschaftet von der Ameise
bis zum Elefanten dort muss man mal
eingreifen es werden Regel geschossen
Hasen Wildschweine und so weiter nur der
Wolf ist die heilige Kuh diese
ampelregierung
sprach der geistige Siebenschläfer der
Söder Regierung Hubert einfacher so wir
halten fest der Wolf ist jetzt eine Kuh
und Wildtiere ziehen offensichtlich im
Wahlkampf achten Sie mal drauf Söder
redet wirklich in einer Tour übers
Entnehmen von Wölfen von Bibern
allerdings von Ottern im Grunde von
allen Tieren die seine Bauern in Bayern
Nerven und ist ja logisch
sehr logisch Bauern gehen zur Wahl
Fischotter eher nicht
und dann ist dann natürlich noch die
Angst vor Bären nachdem in Südbayern
Spuren eines Braunbären aufgetaucht sind
illegal eingereist aus Italien in der
jetzigen Stimmung kann man da alle
Beeren wirklich nur vor solchen
Wanderungen warnen neulich ist zum
Beispiel der Bärenmarke Berber sich zu
Hause aufgebrochen wollte wohl seine
Tante in Bayern besuchen ahnt nichts
Böses und kurz hinter der Grenze
hätte wissen können ne einfach mal
googeln
so und auch wenn Bären genau wie Wölfe
normalerweise Menschen meiden reden wir
natürlich von gefährlichen Raubtieren
vor ein paar Wochen ist ein Jogger in
Norditalien von einer Bären getötet
worden übrigens in einer Region in der
man mit EU Geld die Bären wieder
angesiedelt hat ohne sich so richtig zu
fragen was wenn das klappt
auf der anderen Seite in Slowenien
schaffen sie es sogar mit 1000 Bären zu
leben wichtig wäre dass wir mal aufhören
hier alles zu vermischen wir wollten von
Ihnen wissen sollten Wölfe und Bären
vermehrt abgeschossen werden
doch gleich sollten Bären Wölfe und
Säbelzahntiger abgeschossen werden Wölfe
und Bären in einem Topf wer ruft er
überhaupt an bei solchen Quatsch
Umfragen
hallo Wölfe gerne abknallen werden sind
okay
ja also auch hier nochmal kurz zu den
Fakten Bären Spuren gab es über die
Jahre tatsächlich immer mal wieder in
Bayern und in ganz Deutschland leben
heute
161 Wolfsrudel vor allem im Norden und
ostenlandes im Prinzip sind wir offenbar
total für Artenschutz nur jetzt halt
nicht für alle Arten und für welche
genau das bestimmt immer noch wir Krone
der Schöpfung halt herzlich Willkommen
zu
Tiere suchen ein Zuhause aber doch bitte
nicht hier mit Klaus von Wagner
hallo
und auch heute versuchen wir wieder
unvermittelbare Tiere zu vermitteln
gegen tiefsitzende Vorurteile nehmen wir
mal den Wolf so bei uns in der DNA
abgespeichert als der Perverse Typ der
sich gerne als unsere Oma verkleidet um
unsere Kinder zu fressen es wird sich
schockieren aber das ist nie passiert
nein
der Wolf hat wie alle Arten eine
Funktion im Ökosystem er reguliert die
Bestände von Regen und Hirschen und
hilft damit unseren Freunden den Bäumen
will sagen man muss iq-technisch schon
auf Pantoffeltierchen Niveau sein um zu
sagen der Wolf gehört hier nicht her und
ich sag's mal so ganz deutlich der Wolf
gehört hier nicht her
demonstrand um natürlich hat der Wolf
eine Funktion ich behaupte selbst in der
Stadt könnte nützlich sein
taubenbestände regulieren oder dieselben
rentnerehepaare die in viel zu großen
Häusern wohnen bleiben
nur so ein Gedanke jetzt Oliver jeden
Tag verabschieden sich auf diesem
Planeten rund 150 Arten jeden Tag aber
die Wölfe sind unser Problem wir erleben
das größte Massen Aussterben seit dem
Ende der Dinosaurier vor 70 Millionen
Jahren stimmt vor 70 Millionen Jahren
oder damals live im ZDF übertragen
wann kapieren wir endlich das
Artenschutz unser eigenes Überleben
sichert auch ihres Feldhamster zum
Beispiel machen unsere Böden fruchtbarer
der Hamster selber will da gar nichts
anbauen und die massiv bedrohten Hummeln
bestäuben eben nicht nur Wildpflanzen
sondern auch Tomaten und Auberginen ja
ich bin kein großer Fan von Auberginen
die haben oft sowas mehliges ne
in China
wurden so konsequent Bienen vergiftet
dass die Chinesen es ihren Obstbäumen
bis heute quasi mit der Hand besorgen
müssen
bitte
also wenn ein Chinesen und eine Blüte
sich ganz doll lieb haben
ist jetzt auch egal wir schützen immer
nur Tiere die nicht nerven oder die die
niedlich sind kein Mensch interessiert
sich für den bedrohten blockfisch
obwohl der so eine fröhliche
Ausstrahlung hat oder oder für den
klassischen
nur weil der aussieht wie eine Ratte die
in die Steckdose gepinkelt hat
jede Art ist wichtig fürs Ökosystem
aber ehrlich gesagt will ich ja trotzdem
persönlich keinen Wolf treffen okay
jetzt mal ganz ruhig selbst für diese
sehr unwahrscheinlichen Fall gibt es ein
paar einfache Verhaltensregel man macht
sich so groß wie man kann das macht ist
auch bei anderen Tieren üblich die man
eigentlich Bösartigkeiten planen oder
bösartige Absicht haben sich groß machen
kann und so laut rufen wie man kann
ja also wir machen uns groß ja und rufen
[Musik]
und dann sagt der Wolf hey Klaus und
geht seiner Wege alles klar Klaus von
Wagner vielen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh Gott der Dreh für die